[Music]
jeremiah
is with us he is in jacksonville north
carolina hi jeremiah how are you
i'm doing well how about yourself dave
better than i deserve
what's up all right so to kind of tell
you where i'm at right now
i'm 22 and currently serving in the
military thank you
oh thank you um i have about a year left
on my contract
and i'm planning on attending school
next year once i get out using my gi
bill
um i have about a thousand dollars saved
up in an emergency fund as well as three
to six months of expenses
and have no outstanding debt um
i got about fifty 000 put into a mutual
fund and
with little expenses after i have
budgeted for the month
currently i'm putting that money that's
left over uh
towards that mutual fund yeah but my
question is my question for you is uh
do i continue to keep putting money into
that mutual fund or is there a better
alternative that i could be
putting my money towards like right now
i mean for right now jeremiah i mean the
mutual fund obviously is a it's a great
place
to be putting everything we will say
when you put money in the market
to know that there's going to be
probably a five-year gap there just to
know because the markets will go up and
down so doing short-term savings for
instance this is why we
don't advise putting your emergency fund
in a mutual fund because you're like hey
i need to get it to it quickly
and who knows what the market's going to
do but if you don't have a purchase that
you have
in the next five years um if there's
something to make a house
or college or it's something that's
coming up i mean the mutual fund is
still is still a great spot
to be putting that money because it's
sitting there and growing and it's a
great insurance policy
to say okay you've got the military that
you got the gi benefit for tuition
you've also got a stipend coming right
uh yes they'll give you what's 1200
bucks a month or something
uh roughly yeah and uh so you've got
that stipend coming and if you don't
manage to live off the stipend
and you don't the gi bill doesn't cover
everything then you don't accidentally
wander into a student loan debt
and so that's your backstop to make sure
no student loan debt when you graduate
what are you going to study
um so i just something in
business or finance i haven't really
picked a specific area yet
but that's the direction that i'm
looking forward to going to
like towards my career well you're
you're wise beyond your years you really
have your act together i mean you got 50
000 bucks you've served in the military
you're 22
you've got a fully funded emergency fund
and no debt i take it right
yeah no no debt yeah where'd you learn
all this
um actually it started in high school
but my mom my mom started me pretty
young with dave ramsey
oh okay so you're a financial peace baby
uh yes i actually got to see you in uh
louisville
so okay when you were just a kid just a
little kiddo just wet behind the ears
here's something else man
i'm proud of you i know your mom is
that's very impressive
very impressive a lot of people wishes
their 22 year old sounded like you
and uh it's pretty impressive very well
done yeah you're gonna be in great shape
and just use that 50 000 as a backstop
if you don't touch it which is the
preference right uh and you get out then
rachel's right it will have sat there
and grown for five years or four years
and you'll be able to use it for a great
down payment on your first house
and uh you're gonna be in really really
good shape because that 50 is probably
going to be 75 or 80 by the time you get
there it's awesome so
very good stuff